[Musique]
bonsoir à toutes bonsoir à tous merci
d'être avec nous sur tv78 nous sommes le
mercredi 7 février voici le programme de
ce soir nos élèves ne sont pas des
sardines les enseignants du collège
intercommunal champagigne de la verrière
et Le Ménil Saint-Denis protestent
contre la fermeture de deux classes ils
ont lancé une opération collège mort ce
matin découverte partage dégustation
pour sa 21e édition le Salon du vin et
de la gastronomie de Saint-Germain en
lait proposé une quarantaine de stands
on vous emmène à la découverte de deux
producteurs
yvelinois vous connaissez sûrement la
laine de Merino celle qui tient chaud et
qui est toute douce mais saviez-vous
qu'elle venaent des Yvelines depuis le
18e siècle la Bergerie Nationale de
Rambouillet élève une centaine de
moutons merinos une fierté pour
l'établissement et puis comme d'habitude
l'invité du 78 en 2uxème partie
d'émission ce soir nous parlerons du
tout nouveau petit futé Yveline avec
Isabelle defendal restaurant hôtel
activités ont été soigneusement
sélectionné voilà pour le programme de
ce soir bienvenue dans votre 7 tout de
suite on prend la direction du Ménil
Saint-Denis les portes du collège
Philippe de Champaigne sont restés
closes ce matin une opération nommée
collège mort a été lancée par les
enseignants et les parents d'élèves pour
protester contre la suppression de deux
classes c'est le reportage de Gabriel
Gontier aucun élève à l'horizon ce
mercredi matin au collège intercommunal
Philippe de champEn du Ménil Saint-Denis
et pour cause enseignants et parents
d'élèves organiser une opération collège
mort en réponse à la suppression de deux
classes au sein de l'établissement dès
la rentrée prochaine depuis plusieurs
années et en particulier cette année on
réduit nos moyens pour enseigner et ce
qui va se traduire l'année prochaine par
la fermeture de deux classes ce qui va
monter nos effectifs à 28 à 30 élèves
par classe on est même plus là pour nos
salaires ou nos conditions de travail on
est là juste pour pouvoir enseigner dans
de bonnes conditions faire notre travail
correctement et s'occuper correctement
des élèves et des enfants qu'on nous
confi aujourd'hui le collège Philippe de
Champeigne est un établissement
particulier 30 % des élèves accueillis
ont des besoins spécifiques liés à des
handicaps ou appartenant à des zones
d'éducation prioritaires pour les
parents d'élèves l'augmentation des
effectifs dans les classes dégraderait
les conditions de travail moi j'ai par
exemple j'ai posé la question à mon fils
dis mais si tu vous retrouvez à 30 par
classe qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce que ça va
te faire son questionnement ça a été
mais on va être trop nombreux comment on
va faire pour travailler en fait ça va
être trop bruillant un sentiment que
partagent les maires des communes de la
verrière et du Ménil Saint-Denis venu
apporter leur soutien aux manifestants
tout comme le député William Martinet
moi je suis en désaccord avec cette
logique comptable au sein de l'éducation
nationale qui est de dire il faut
supprimer des postes il faut fermer des
classes pour faire des économies et que
la priorité ça devrait être l'intérêt
des élèves si on veut que le collège
reste attractif il faut assumer de
conserver des moyens reçu par l'Académie
en janvier dernier professeurs et
parents d'élèves n'avaient pas été
satisfait des réponses données d'autres
opérations comme celle-ci pourrai être
organisées après les vacances scolaires
c'est l'heure à présent de faire le
point sur le reste des informations du
jour à retenir dans les
ivelines et c'est avec vous Michel
midoro bonsoir bonsoir On commence ces
infos du jour avec l'hommage national
rendu aux 42 victimes françaises suite à
l'assaut du Hamas le 7 octobre dernier
Emmanuel Macron a présidé la cérémonie
aux invalide ce matin d'autres
cérémonies se sont aussi tenues un peu
partout en France comme à Montini le
Bretonneux effectivement Mathilde la
commune de Montin Bretonneux a tenu sa
cérémonie dans la la salle du conseil
municipal de l'Hôtel de Ville un moment
de recueillement avec un discours de
rassemblement de paix et de fraternité
s'en est suivi une minute de silence
avant une Marseillaise une cinquantaine
de personnes étaient présentes parmi
elles le rabat de 50 ans en iveline
Mandel nisambum on l'écoute c'est bien
sûr la mémoire des victimes mais surtout
c'est combattre l'antisémitisme et que
cette fois-ci sera vraiment le plus
jamais c'est-à-dire accepter l'autre et
être pour une fois tous ensemble en pays
en harmonie on parle en Israël de
plusieurs centaines de personnes qui se
sont cet après-midi réunies au même
moment où le président de la République
faisait son hommage aux Invalides
c'est-à-dire que ça a été pris pas
seulement bien pris se sentir soutenu
dans un même combat une information qui
vient de nous parvenir à présent Michell
d'après Le Parisien le Conseil des
ministres du jour a acté le départ du du
préfet des Yvelines Jean-Jacques BR oui
Mathilde Jean-Jacques Brau quittera ses
fonctions à la préfecture du département
le 2 mars prochain arrivé en avril 2018
le Haut- fonctionnaire de 68 ans aura
notamment géré la crise sanitaire
l'assassinat de Samuel paatti ou encore
la préparation des Jeux Olympiques dans
les Yvelines en connaî son remplaçant il
s'agit de Frédéric rose actuel
conseiller à la sécurité du président de
la République Emmanuel Macron on
poursuit ces infos du jour avec le
Festival du film francophone pour la
jeunesse qui débute aujourd'hui au
Mureau jusqu'au 13 février débute la 3e
édition de ce rendez-vous sur le 7e arme
étant à l'honneur des films francophones
venus du monde entier pour la sélection
des films adaptés aux enfants jusqu'à 12
ans comme Marinette de Virginie verrier
ou la vie de ma mère de Julien à
Carpentier ce samedi 10 février des
ateliers seront proposés au public
autour du doublage de voix du montage et
du trucage une belle occasion de
découvrir tous les secrets de la
réalisation des techniques du cinéma on
regarde tout de suite un extrait de la
bande annonce d'un des films
sélectionnés pour ce festival je suis
trop fan je peux prendre un
selfie non juste avec
diva
[Musique]
Arte qu'on fe connaissance il quoi
dégage
AC je ne voyage pas en S madame vous
l'ai dit pour la 1e fois notre chat est
un
[Musique]
sécurist on parle des chiens et des
chats Michel on continue avec une
information insolite la centrale canine
l'organisme coordonnant le milieu du
chien en France a dévoilé le top 3 des
chiens préférés des français en Île-de
France et le chouchou des Franciliens
c'est le Stafford bulrier avec
871 naissances enregistrées au Livre des
Origines Françaises en 2020 23 il est
aussi appelé stffi c'est un Molos de
petite taille parfois victime des idées
reçues ce n'est pas un chien catégorisé
pas obligatoire de lui faire porter une
musolière dans les espaces publics à la
deuxième place on retrouve le golden
retriever le cavalier king charles
complète le podium bien merci beaucoup
Michel je suis très fan du cavalier king
charles personnellement très bien moi je
suis plutôt border colis merci beaucoup
Michel pour toutes ces informations et
comme d'habitude si vous aussi vous
voyez une image ou une information qui
vous a marqu marqu n'hésitez pas à nous
la partager sur les réseaux sociaux en
utilisant le hashtag 78
news toujours aussi riche en goût et en
découverte le weekend dernier avait lieu
la 21e édition du Salon des vins et de
la gastronomie organisé par le lyonce
club de Saint-Germain en lait une
quarantaine d'exposants présentai leur
savoir-faire l'occasion pour nous de
découvrir deux producteurs yvelinois
c'est le reportage de Michel elmidoro et
de Clara de Frutos foie gras de
Normandie vin du langue d'un croussillon
ou encore escargot des Yvelines les
produits du terroir était à l'honneur ce
weekend au manège royal de Saint-Germain
en lait pour sa 21e édition le Salon du
vin et de la gastronomie accueillait une
quarantaine d'exposants l'objectif
donner l'eau à la bouche aux visiteurs
pour faire découvrir les produits des
différentes régions françaises très très
bon producteur avec un échantillon un
peu de toutes les régions ils peuvent
parler de leur métier et euh ils peuvent
vraiment transmettre leur passion sur
les produits qu'ils font apprécier des
produits authentique et traditionnel
escargot au beurre persiller feilleté en
passant par des croquilles cet élevage
yvelinois d'escargot proche de Mantel
jolie démontrer son savoir-faire une
production locale de l'élevage jusqu'à
la vente moi je n'élève que du gros gris
c'est l'escargot vraiment que l'on
trouve qu'en élevage et et qui s'élève
en 6 mois de temps il est élevé en
France donc ça c'est déjà quelque chose
qui est important et puis après tout est
fait donc sur place l'élevage la cuisine
et après on vend à la maison on a un
magasin et puis après on fait quelques
salons pour faire connaître justement
les produits parmi les producteurs
ivelinois il y a aussi h au miel
installé depuis 5 ans au m nul dans la
Haute Vallée de Chevreuse l'entreprise
produit près de 500 kg de miel par an
bah c'est vraiment un miel local un miel
local qui est brut de ruche c'està-dire
qu'on on on on le récolte tel que avec
un chatignier très parfumé excellent
pour les pour les pour les gâteaux les
pains d'épices et surtout un miel blanc
de
printemps fruitier et cerisier près de
2000 curieux ont répondu présent cette
année au salon du vin et de la
gastronomie prochaine édition en mars
2025 on va parler de sport à présent
dans votre 78 un grand gala de boxe est
organisé ce samedi au complexe sportif
Europe à hlencour au programme trois
combats pro et se combats amateurs on
écoute les boxeurs evvelinois tête
d'affiche de ce rendez-vous au micro de
michaell
[Musique]
lmidoro ça fait super plaisir parce que
on boxe à la maison donc déjà on est
chez nous sur nos terres nos proches
vont pouvoir venir nous voir nous donner
de la force nous supporter donc donc ça
fait super plaisir pareil ça fait
toujours plaisir en box chez nous il y
aura nos proches mais c'est aussi là
qu'on doit prouver c'est aussi là là
qu'on va un peu plus avoir à pression
mais il y a pas de souci on SAA la
[Musique]
gérer pour l'instant je la ressens pas
euh peut-être qu'elle devrait être là
pour l'instant je la ressens pas tant
que ça on verra le jourgie si elle monte
mais en tout cas j'espère qu'on SAA en
faire de bonnes choses moi non plus je
ressens pas trop de pression pour le
moment me connaissant je pense que
j'aurais pas forcément de pression le
jour J non plus par rapport au fait
qu'on soit des tête d'affiche d'ailleurs
il en manque un Nassim mitouche qui est
notre camarade et et notre ami et qui
boxe mais qui pas être là ce soir donc
on est trois têtes d'affiche par rapport
à ça non j'ai j'ai pas forcément de
pression et je pense pas en ressentir
par rapport à ce point là en tout cas le
jour
J venez nombreux venez nous donner de la
force parce que on va faire le
spectacle en tout cas on va vous faire
des des gros combats des beaux combats
on va tout faire pour et en plus avec la
victoire ça serait laass sur le gâteau
mais c'est pour ça qu'on s'entraînnait
et et puis ça va le faire venez nombreux
amener tout le monde ça va être une
super soirée il y aura pas que nous il y
aura aussi des boxeurs amateurs de tous
niveaux il y aura des débutants des
novices des élites donc ça va être une
super soirée boxe venez nombreux ça va
être
[Musique]
cool un mot de cinéma également dans
votre 78 le mercredi des réalisateurs
yvelinois vous proposent de découvrir ou
de redécouvrir des films qui ont été
tournés dans le département ce soir
Thomas Salazar fait un focus sur le
thriller l réalisé par Paul veroven avec
Isabelle
huper est-ce que dans le film l de Paul
veroven sorti en 2016 vous avez reconnu
les rues de la ville de la selle-
saint-clou il faut changer toutes les
serrures en haut et en bas j'ai quelque
chose à vous dire et oui c'est ces rues
sont parfaites pour l'ambiance du film
qui a un film très très sombre avec des
grandes maisons dans dans un milieu de
la bourgeoisie c'est pour ça que le
réalisateur a choisi la ville de la
sou en vrai et tu vas
bien mais il y a un fou qui
re je porterai aucun
jugement la prochaine fois que vous
verrez Isabelle luperre en train de
courir dans les films à la recherche de
son agresseur vous reconnaîtrez la selle
sa-ou
[Musique]
et d'ailleurs ce film a également été
tourné dans une villa à Saint-Germain en
lait on poursuit cette émission avec un
nouveau numéro des animaux du 78 on vous
emmène à la découverte du mouton Minos
de la Bergerie Nationale de Rambouillet
une histoire qui dure depuis le 18e
siècle Gérald rose je suis le
responsable d'exploitation ici à la
Bergerie Nationale de
[Musique]
Rambouillet le mérineuse de Rambouillet
est une race historique qui est élevée à
Rambouillet depuis le 18e siècle c'est
le roi Louis XV à l'époque qui a importé
cette race en provenance d' pagne pour
ses qualités lainièires et donc c'est
une race qui a été sélectionnée et
élevée à rambouillé depuis 1786 pour
être très
[Musique]
précis alors la spécificité du Minos
évidemment c'est la qualité de sa laine
tout d'abord sa finesse c'est une laine
très fine qui permet de pouvoir porter
les vêtements qui sont faits avec de la
laine de Minos à même la peau c'est une
laine qui ne va pas piquer parce que
contrairement à la plupart des autres
races qui ont une finesse alors qu'on
qu'on mesure en micron euh qui va être
de l'ORD de 30 à 40 microns pour les
races générales en France on va dire
pour le Minos on va être entre 18 et 20
microns donc quasiment moitié au niveau
de la finesse et donc ça permetre
d'avoir une laine de très bonne qualité
alors c'est des animaux qui ont de la
laine blanche uniquement ils ont
toujours été sélectionné sur la couleur
de la laine pour avoir uniquement des
animaux à laine blanche et enfin c'est
aussi des animaux qui ont une grande
quantité de laine c'estàd qu'on voit sur
les béliers qui sont derrière moi qu'ils
ont de la laine du bout des pattes
jusqu'au bout du nez donc vraiment sur
toute la surface du corps ce qui permet
qu'un bélier Minos par exemple de
rembouiller va pouvoir produire entre 6
et 8 kg de laine chaque
[Musique]
année la tonte se fait une fois par an
euh au printemps donc là cette année la
tonde des mérinos aura lieu à la fin du
mois d'avril et voilà ça permet de les
débarrasser de leur toison avant les
beaux jours et avant l'arrivée des des
périodes chaudes pour pour leur confort
tout simplement parce que c'est des
animaux qui sont pas capables de de muer
donc de perdre leur toison
[Musique]
eux-mêmes c'est une fierté parce que
c'est un patrimoine historique comme je
disais au début c'est une race qui a été
exportée dans le monde entier au 19e
siècle il y a eu ce qu'on a appelé la
minisation c'est la diffusion de de
béliers de la race mérineuse de
rambouillé dans en France tout d'abord
et ensuite dans le monde entier sur tous
les continents dans le but d'améliorer
les performances lénires de des races
locales et donc aujourd'hui si on va en
Nouvelle-Zélande en Australie ou en
Amérique du Sud on retrouvera des
troupeaux issus du mineuse de
[Musique]
rambouille
et c'est bientôt l'heure de passer à
l'invité du 78 mais avant je vous
propose de jeter un coup d'œil à la
météo de
demain demain matin le ciel sera
toujours aussi couvert etpluvieux dans
les evelines côté température de la
douceur il fera en moyenne 11°gr
l'après-midi la pluie devrait cesser de
tomber sauf dans le secteur de Oudan
niveau température il fera 14°gr du côté
de Mantel jolie 13 à Houdon et
Versailles et 12°gr à rambouiller et
demain nous fêterons la sainte
Jacqueline c'est l'heure à présent de
l'invité du
[Musique]
78 et l'invité de ce soir c'est la
responsable de l'édition du tout nouveau
petit futé Eveline Isabelle deffendal
bonsoir bonsoir alors l'édition 2024 du
Petit Futé Eveline que vous voyez ici
présent est sorti aujourd'hui dans les
librairies qu'est-ce qu'on retrouve
dedans c'est ça alors on retrouve pour
ce qui est du guide départemental donc
on a les
loisirs nous avons les hébergements ça
peut être des hébergements atypiques
aussi et nous avons donc les produits de
bouche et puis le patrimoine de Pierre
le patrimoine naturel qu'est-ce qui a
changé depuis la dernière édition qui
date de il y a 4 ans euh oui à peu près
puisqueen fait c'est les événements qui
nous ont obligé à nous arrêter vu qu'on
est sur le terrain aussi euh en fait on
a fait un petit peu comme le Besteller
breton le guide morbillant qui est
vraiment très intéressant parce qu'on a
travaillé sur les terroirs en se
libérant un petit peu des agglomérations
des aglos et et en fait on travaille sur
des cheminements touristiques des
cheminements voilà on est on a décidé
donc de le créer en cinq parties
avec diviser donc le le territoire
yvelinois en cinq parties ce qui est
plus intéressant dans le sens où on a
Versailles qui rayonne
et ça permet aussi aux autres d'avoir un
peu de lumière aussi et donc vous me le
disiez aussi a des nouvelles catégories
qu' n avait pas avant oui alors on a des
nouvelles catégories avec Marine mon
auteur qui a bien travaillé sur tout ce
qui est culturel ça peut être des
auteurs les auteurs dans le les auteurs
donc qui ont vécu dans les ivelines les
écrivains célèbres des écrivains
célèbres on a aussi même des humoristes
on n'est pas sectaire on parle aussi du
présent et puis qu'est-ce qu'on a
d'autre on a des des découvertes des de
la culture aussi musicale on a on parle
des maisons aussi de de certaines
personnalités voilà on est on est on a
des vraiment on a considéré que créer un
guide avec une partie magazine était
intéressant aussi c'est vrai que notre
territoire est riche alors pour en
apprendre un peu plus sur l'écriture de
ce guide 100 % Eveline je vous propose
de regarder le reportage de Gabriel
Gontier fin janvier l'équipe et les
partenaires du Petit Futé se sont réunis
au domaine de la
jeunesse après 4 ans d'attente et près
d'un an de travail l'édition 2024 du
Petit Futé Eveline va enfin voir le jour
dans cette nouvelle version restaurant
hôtel ou encore lieu culturel autour de
chez vous ont été soigneusement
sélectionnés c'est la qualité de des
produits la qualité d'accueil
la qualité aussi de géographique aussi
on ne booute personne dans dans la
qualité on peut avoir du restaurant
étoilé comme des petites auberges avec
une petite grand-mère qui fait des plats
justement de grand-mère cette année
l'auteur de cette édition est marine
pasqueet SAES pour cette yvelinoise
d'adoption l'écriture du guide lui a
permis de redécouvrir le département il
y a un travail de recherche parce que le
guide n'avait pas été mis à jour depuis
2020 donc il fallait ben vérifier au
niveau des prix des si les restaurants
étaient toujours ouverts les nouveautés
qui se sont ouverts entre-temps même moi
qui habite dans les ielines ça me donne
de bonnes idées de balade depuis plus de
40 ans le Petit Futé est un
incontournable des guides touristiques
faire partie de la sélection du livre
est une fierté pour les établissements
pour nous la fierté c'est d'être sur la
couverture c'est que le domaine de
dpierre se trouve à la sur la couverture
ça veut dire que ça y est notre notre
travail depuis 5 ans de mise en place de
la notoriété du domaine de Dierre bien
évidemment on devient un des monuments
emblématiques de desivlin on espère que
ça va faire venir du monde qui vont
venir nous voir sur ce beau domaine où
on a à la fois du patrimoine des animaux
de la nature et on représente assez bien
les zvelines pour ça et des visiteurs
dans les zvelines il devrait y en avoir
en 2024 avec les Jeux olympiques et
paralympiques pour répondre à la demande
près de 15000 exemplaires seront en
vente dès le 7
février alors est-ce que ce guide d'
environ 280 pages s'adresse 288
exactement s'adresse uniquement du coup
aux touristes ou il s'adresse aussi aux
yvelinois alors les Yvelinois sont des
touristes ils se baladent le weekend
c'est des touristes qui ne sont pas
occasionnels donc non c'est pour les
Yvelinois pour les Franciliens on a
beaucoup de Parisiens qui arrivent à
dépasser le périf ce qui est très
compliqué parfois euh pour aller passer
une semaine au mois d'août même dans les
ivelines HE les ivelines c'est une terre
où il retrouve de la campagne pour
s'évader on a des collines la campagne
on a la scène on a la forêt une des plus
grandes forêts quand même la la forêt de
rondbouillet par exemple enfin c'est
22000 hectares ce qui est quand même
énorme on a d'autres forêts aussi on a
on a des champs enfin c'est très
bucolique aussi on a un patrimoine de
Pierre assez fabuleux comme on a aussi
le voilà on a le château de d'ampierre
qui est en train de se d'être restauré
par Monsieur mulèz dont j'ai pu faire
l'interview donc voilà on a un extrait
en tout cas de l'interview que de de de
de voilà sur le le le château et les
millions qu'il a pu mettre aussi en tant
que
messè donc c'est une découverte incente
même pour moi alors comment est-ce que
vous avez sélectionné les villes aussi
parce qu'elles sont très nombreuses
comment est-ce que vous décidez de telle
ville va être dans le Petit Futé Eveline
2024 alors ça c'est un travail assez
ancien quand on a démarré le guide
Eveline après on peut très bien faire
évoluer ça moi j'aime bien aussi
intégrer des découvertes et des villages
euh il y a un côté toujours découverte
dans le guide c'est vraiment le on on
fait un petit cheminement comme ça et on
fait des surprises au lecteurs puisqu'on
a des on a des habitués puis on a des
nouveaux chaque année qui décident de
prendre tel mésime entre
guillemets donc on a un cheminement on
essaie de de couvrir le territoire après
c'est une question aussi de de ce qu'on
veut présenter de la ville il y a des
critères aussi que vous devez suivre
alors les critères c'est c'est le
patrimoine de Pierre c'est les produits
de bouche c'est tout ce qui est logement
et c'est aussi les loisirs et donc plus
une ville est riche dans ces critères
plus elle va elle va avoir une à trois
étoiles alors c'est pas une on a pas
d'étoil nous d'accord nous on n pas
d'étoiles on on on a des des on a des
petits soleils sur le site par exemple
pour les avis mais on on donne des avis
plutôt on arrive à on développe le un
peu le sujet on parle de de bons
produits on parle de produits frais on
parle de de de décoration on parle de
situation géographique aussi et du coup
est-ce que vous avez tout testé
absolument tout testé ce qu'il y a dans
le guide oui alors on les a testé un
jour après il faut qu'on puisse retester
c'est-à-dire que on peut très bien avoir
un restaurant qui avait un très bon
niveau qui correspond à notre charte
parce qu'on a une charte de qualité qui
faut respecter pour rentrer dans le
guide et le chef part et en fait le
niveau descend et ça on se retrouve un
peu piégé c'est que nous ça correspond
plus à notre charte et ça c'est pas
possible donc c'est quoi cette charte de
qualité alors la charte c'est euh les
des bons produits une manière aussi de
faire c'est-à-dire qu'on évite un peu
les surgelés quoi dans les restaurants
le fait maison c'est le fait maison
c'est aussi une manière de de de d'être
peut-être local aussi quand on peut on
n'est pas non plus intégriste là-dessus
on fait attention aussi à ce que les uns
les autres puissent quand même
travailler comme il comme ils le peuvent
hein c'est on sait très bien euh c'est
le côté
aussi esthétique on aime bien ça aussi
après ça peut être un établissement
aussi réputé une institution et puis une
petite auberge qui n'a aucune lumière et
là on va aller la chercher elle pour la
mettre en lumière parce qu'on adore les
découvertes et donc tout ça ça a dû
demander énormément de recherches ces
recherches elles se font uniquement par
l'équipe du Petit Futé ou est-ce que
vous avez aussi demandé aux locaux aux
associations de vous aideri alors c'est
mê même pas une aide en tant que tel
hein c'est au gré des discussions euh
mon auteur me propose des choses aussi
donc elle va elle-même voir certains
égoûter à l'aveugle parce que le but
c'est quand même voilà de passer et moi
après elle me dit ben ce serait
intéressant d'aller d'aller discuter
avec la direction ou le créateur ou le
voilà c'est un peu ça parce que on
rentre un peu dans les secrets des des
uns des autres on a des anecdotes aussi
assez folles enfin c'est donc voilà on
est sur le TER
moi je suis beaucoup sur le terrain mon
auteur l'est aussi de temps en temps et
l'idée c'est que l'ensemble du guide
soit testé vu et
cetera dans les créations et les
nouveautés je ne les mets pas en tout
cas je les propose pas la au redacchef
SI et à la maquette donc si on n' pas
été les visité enfin je suis pas allé
discuter avec le directeur ou le
propriétaire et voir sur place d'accord
et donc vous êtes venu avec avec la
plaque Petit Futé 2024 qui est d'ors et
déjà c'est ça donc cette plaque c'est le
label tout simplement si vous
correspondez si vous correspondez à la
charte et vous rentrez dans le
guide vous pouvez le l'obtenir donc ça
prend combien de temps pour écrire
sortir un guide comme celui-ci alors ça
peut prendre 7 mois mais celui-là a pris
un an d'accord on a parce que il y avait
beaucoup beaucoup trop de choses à
mettre en place puisque on changa la
chtein l'organisation du Guide a a a
changé du coup il a fallu aussi qu'on
fasse un pingpong dans les équipes euh
voilà il y a des discussion moi je suis
sûr je crapahute je me balade beaucoup
dans les Yvelines et donc il y a des
choses que le rédacteur en chef veut ne
veut pas forcément et je il faut
discuter pour lui expliquer pourquoi
c'est judicieux et de le mettre est-ce
que vous espérez plus de vente aussi
alors on sait que c'est c'est quelque
chose qui se vend très bien qui plaît
beaucoup mais est-ce que vous espérez
plus de vente de vente notamment avec
les Jeux olympiques de Paris 2024 il y a
toujours des progressions par rapport à
tout un tas d'événements mais oui on a
voilà on nous on on nous sollicite aussi
même pour des guides en parallèle de
celui-là des guides sur mesure justement
en vue des Jeux Olympiques on est on est
sur plusieurs guides qui qui viennent
d'arriver et qui vont certainement être
en vente aussi en parallèle des ielin et
sur les ivelines effectivement il y a je
crois qu'on a six épreuves dans les
Yvelines ce qui est assez énorme ce qui
fait que oui oui ça il va y avoir une
aspiration d'autant que le guide se on
peut le on peut le consulter en cinq
langues même plus après mais pour
l'instant c'est cinq langues l'allemand
le chinois l'espagnol le français
l'anglais donc oui on a c'est même pas
de l'espoir on pense que on est même sûr
de de d'avoir une belle aspiration comme
ça alors vous parlez de nombreuses
anecdotes au fur et à mesure de
l'écriture de ce livre est-ce que vous
en vous avez un coup de cœur vous
personnel concernant un restaurant par
exemple alors on a eu on a des top 5
donc je vais pas vraiment citer les top
5 parce que il y en a qui vont être un
peu jaloux des autres sinon mais non il
y a des découvertes humaines des des des
gens qui touchent des la manière de
travailler
aussi j'ai par exemple je j'arrive
jamais à retenir le nom de de la c'est à
c'est à h sur moldre donc c'est les haut
du Val c'est un git de Gilberte qui est
qui qui est très bucoli qui est qui est
un vrai petit paradis moi je le
conseille vraiment alors pour
l'anecdote j'ai découvert un village qui
est Montainville c'est le village de
Bourville il est enterré là-bas
d'ailleurs et de fil en aiguille j'ai
découvert donc une auberge avec euh la
cuisine des lulus Lucile et Lucy d'c qui
sont deux jeunes euh cuisinières enfin
des des des des euh des filles qui sont
vraiment adorables et qui font aussi de
la cuisine très recherchée très très
élaboré aussi et très simple aussi une
sorte de mélange comme ça gastronomique
et donc c'était intéressant de d'aller
les voir et en face on avait le un git
intéressant puisque c'était la
fauconnerie du roi qui est en fait un
ancien bâtiment du 17e qui appartenait
avec une avec un mur de 2 ou 3 m et avec
des écuries et qui appartenait au grand
foconier du roi Louis XI puis du roi
Louis XIV euh ils élevaient les faucons
dans cet endroit donc il reste encore le
bâtiment l'intérieur est préservé et ça
a été vraiment fabuleux et l'anecdote
c'est que j'ai vu des photos de Johnny
deppp assis dans le fauteuil en face de
de là où j'étais et en fait il est il a
pris ces quartiers là il a il a loué
tout le bâtiment et tous les locaux il a
mis à la porte les propriétaires
euh benah en fait pour le film de
malwayne My Wayne euh sur Louis X et
donc voilà et l'équipe venait manger
chez les lulus chez les les
dans l'auberge donc de motinville donc
c'est voilà c'est des petites anecdotes
sympasord oui c'est une belle anecdote
et puis il allait dans les écuries pour
peindre faire sa musique voilà il
faisait sa vie c'est oui oui il
changeait les les les les les les
meubles historiques de place des choses
comme ça mais moi j'adore ces petites
anecdotes c'est c'est assez sympa et
bien merci beaucoup isabellefandal
d'avoir répondu à nos questions et
d'avoir accepté notre invitation en
plateau je le rappelle vous êtes la
responsable d'édition du tout nouveau
petit futé Eveline 202 4 alors si vous
êtes intéressé il est d'ors et déjà
disponible en librairie et c'est la fin
de cette émission merci pour votre
fidélité je vous souhaite une belle
soirée sur tv78 prenez soin de
[Musique]
vous